you
hello everybody welcome to the fifth
Bitcoin trading video in this video what
we're going to be doing is adding
another axis so we can do the relative
strength index so with that let's go
ahead and get started um first thing
that we're going to go ahead and do is
what we sometimes like when we look at
this for example let's run this one real
quick the granularity of this data I
mean it's nice that it's so thick you
know
but you might actually you know want to
deal with maybe adding an exponential
moving average or something like that to
it but for the purposes here I don't
really want to do that just yet I'd
rather throw the RSI on here and make
the RSI possibly of a the exponential
moving average or not at all just have
the RSI using the raw data and then pass
through a long time frame etc there's a
lot of different things that we can do
for that so what we want to do though is
just at least add the RSI here so the
next thing that we want to do is just
come down here and basically we want to
define axes instead of just plot plot
right so what we'll do is we'll come
down here and we'll just say ax 1 equals
P LT dot sub ply to grid and then in
here we throw in some variables how big
is this grid it's gonna be a 6 by 4 grid
and then we put here where it starts
this one will start at 2 and then 0 over
and it will row span 4 and call span
also 4 so obviously it takes up a 4 by 4
it and we have a 6 by 4 so we have
another 2 by 4 that we can put the RSI
on basically is the idea there so now
what we'll do is well we can go ahead
and get rid of this because we're not
going to do that anymore and instead
we'll replace it with a a X 1 dot plot
and we're going to plot BTC date R and
then we're gonna plot
BTC price our and that's really all we
have to throw in there now the next
thing that we want to do is let's make
sure the grid shows we are going to
compare it so we'll add a true to the
grid and now we're going to add an
access to an access to is going to be
very similar so I'm just going to copy
and paste this in here it will also be a
6x4 this one will start at 0 0 it will
only span two rows but it will still
span four columns and also we're going
to want the grid to be here as well so
grid true all that's good so let's save
that and run that and see what we're
looking at and sure enough now we've got
the plot down here and we've got a plot
up here ready for some points so now
what we want to do is go ahead and add
that our aside to this and instead of
going through the RSI I've already
covered it you toriel on the RSI so if
you want to know exactly how to do that
check out the tutorial on the RSI
otherwise what we'll do is head over to
let me type it bring it over sent Dexcom
that's my website come over here over to
about us
hover over that click on tutorials once
you're there scroll down to this part
right here and click on the tutorial and
sample code for the financial indicators
also I will just note a lot of these
indicators that are here we can use them
with Bitcoin and some of them that
aren't natively easy to do with Bitcoin
you can still do so every indicator here
we can actually do in Bitcoin but anyway
we want to go and click on sample code
with the empty slot just click on that
one and then scroll down a little bit we
don't need the entire code we're just
looking for the RSI part which is right
here at the top so just highlight that
go all the way up copy that and then
we're done here and close out of this
one so we don't need that anymore
and then go to the top of this script
and then underneath how far back paste
that RSI function now the only thing
that I would change about this RSI
function is n right n equals 14 probably
not going to be the best we would want a
much higher one most likely but we'll
get there in a minute so
the next thing that we want to do is
actually use the RSI functionality so
now what we're going to do is we come
down here and we're going to say RSI
line so this is just the RSI part equals
RSI a func
and then what do we want to use this
function on well we're going to do it on
the prices so BTC price array and then
well that's let's see uh that and then
we can specify a new end if we wanted so
we could say N equals something else for
now we'll leave it at 14 but then we'll
edit it as we go so now what we can do
is a x2 dot apply and we can plot P BTC
date array and then our si line and then
we also already did the grids so in fact
let me move the grid we'll move that
down here
everything's ordered nicely I'll wear
that grid go I guess I'll just type it
again um x2 that we would call the RSI
line we plot the RSI line now the other
thing we want to do is let's go ahead
and add those lines so a x2 dot H line
where do we want it we want it the 60
mark to start color equals red and then
a x2 dot H line one at the 40 color
equals green so these lines denote
overbought and oversold scenarios so
this one at the 60 mark with it being
red if it's above that line we're saying
hey that's over overbought anyway x2 dot
set and only ticks we really even care
about Y ticks are 60 and 40 so we're
literally going to do 40 60 and that's
the only lines that will even show and
then we'll you know add the grid of
course and then plot show so now let's
go ahead and save that
and we'll run that and we had a issue
h-line what do we do wrong okay so what
we need to do is make this axis h ax h
line sorry about that
save that run it again you might get
this little error but don't worry about
it
yeah all right so here's our RSI a very
beautiful RSI right here guys
so notably this is why we have an issue
with the the time frame so instead of
like where is our definition of it here
so 14 let's make it 1400 right so now we
look at it and let's just see what it
looks like now and so now obviously
we've chilled out this line a little bit
so really here you can see all the
points where it has been pretty much
overbought and oversold but of course
we're going to want to go ahead and make
this number a little bit smaller so we
can just divide it in half to like seven
hundred a lot of this is going to be
kind of like what kind of trading you're
looking to actually do with this stuff
but anyway we'll run it again so we're
still not crossing over any line really
and so let's not really should because
it's gonna start getting pretty busy but
again like all this stuff right here you
know you're generally going to be maybe
looking at a time frame that's like
maybe this size right oh we haven't tied
the axes either let's go ahead and do
that as well uh so right after zero zero
do a share X equals ax 1 comma um that
way they'll share the same axes so let
me make sure I I wasn't sure if I got
rid of that plot or not so let's run
that again um wait for it to pop up okay
now they're sharing the same axis so
when you zoom in to a specific spot
they'll share the axes so anyway now we
can see where we're going here now
really at this point I would really like
to see this as being called an oversold
situation and we don't have any oversold
situation or overbought situations so we
definitely want to chain
that to where the obvious points are
clearly overbought and oversold so let's
continue editing this until we find kind
of a happy medium so let's run it again
and at least here we have one scenario
where we were overbought in one scenario
where we were in theory oversold and it
just kind of depends on like where
you're looking you know like because
this was a very volatile time right when
it was shooting up like this and so boy
like right here I would really like this
line right down here to be over this to
be said hey that's oversold and this to
say hey that's overbought you know and
so the more we kind of mess with this we
can slowly maybe get to that point we
are having a very hard time doing so
anyway so you'll just want to keep
playing with it you can kind of you can
change the bars as well to get maybe
closer to what you're actually looking
to get here but at least here where it
was clearly very volatile we are picking
it up there but it just kind of depends
on what kind of trading you're looking
to actually do right because like right
here it clearly picked it up so it's
kind of weird that this is like anything
pi the RSI hey that's a really stable
guys I don't think so
from 880 to 850 but you got to also
remember that bitcoin is just incredibly
volatile so it is going to be kind of
difficult to get it to always be what
you're looking for and at least for us
I'm kind of looking to get a lot of
trades in here so I almost want it to be
more sensitive than you you might think
that you'd want it to be but it really
just depends on like what you're
actually looking for so anyway that's
looking at it visually so like as you're
kind of playing around because the next
video we're actually going to talk about
back testing and back testing isn't
really we're not gonna have any graph so
when you're doing the back test this can
kind of help you get an idea for like
what you're actually looking at so like
if we look if we did
let's do N equals 100 or something so
let's say but in especial
with N equals 14 we were seeing some
pretty crazy stuff and it was like well
I don't really know that I even want to
follow that one but whenever we were you
know looking at it you can clearly see
with your eyes hey that's a bad idea to
trade with N equals 14 right and then
when we change it to N equals 1400 you
can also say hey it's a bad idea we're
probably not going to get any trades
right so so you can kind of use it to
your advantage that way to look at it
visually and see what you're asking it
to do but in the next video what we're
actually going to do is start to program
in automatic trades and act like we were
automatically trading at various RSI
values and see if we're profitable at
those values so that's what we're going
to be doing in the next video so stay
tuned for that video as always thanks
for watching thanks for your support
your subscriptions if you do like the
videos you can also donate to my Bitcoin
wallet the address is in the description
and again thanks for watching